hey this is very very strange there is a
new report that radical trumpist
republican congressman matt gates under
investigation for a number of different
potential crimes including trafficking
of a minor across state lines for sexual
purposes we have a report now that matt
gates sought a trump pardon
before before
the trump riots
this is um this is strange because it
raises the question of why did he want
that pardon newsweek report says
florida republican congressman matt
gates
had been personally pushing for a broad
presidential pardon from donald trump
before and after the january sixth
attack the house committee investigating
the riot revealed one of the biggest
revelations from thursday's hearing was
the testimony naming six republicans
including gates and others who wanted
clemency from trump before he left
office by the way that includes louis
gomert and marjorie taylor-green
additionally alabama representative mo
brooks allegedly allegedly sent an email
on january 11 seeking quote all-purpose
pardons for every lawmaker who objected
to electoral votes from arizona and
pennsylvania
gates has been contacted for comment
the other gates part in her recorded
testimony it was described how gates had
been asking for a presidential pardon
before the other republican lawmakers
accused of being involved in attempts to
overturn the 2020 election quote gates
was personally pushing for a pardon and
he was doing so since early december i'm
not sure why said hutchinson he reached
out to me to ask if he could have a
meeting with meadows about receiving a
presidential pardon eric hershman a
trump white house lawyer also said in
testimony played on thursday gates
wanted a wide-reaching pardon from trump
quote the general tone was we may get
prosecuted because we were defensive of
the president's position on these things
the pardon he was discussing requesting
was as broad as you could describe from
the beginning of time up until today for
any and all things he mentioned nixon
and i said nixon's pardon was never
nearly that broad
this is very strange so the natural
question is why did matt gates so early
uh and so broadly
want a pre-emptive blanket pardon
the natural speculation is was gates
trying to crowbar in a pre-emptive
pardon
for the things he's being investigated
for personally well it's merely
speculation
but it's a reasonable question to ask
the issue is most of the stuff let me
i'll put it a different way
many of the things gates is being
investigated for are state crimes and
not federal crimes and a presidential
pardon wouldn't help you with state
crimes that being said the interstate
trafficking of minors that's a federal
crime and that's a really big deal so
one speculation is gates figured you
know everybody's going to try to get
pardons and we're going to say it's for
supporting trump's view about the
election and trying to fix it and all
these different things but maybe i can
sneak in some help with what i may be up
against criminally for my personal
activities that's one possibility it is
amazing that we regularly are charging
regularly and quickly charging all sorts
of different people poor people
non-white people people not in positions
of power for insignificant oftentimes
kind of contrived charges the war on
drugs you could argue is contrived at
the big picture
as we know the origins of it to be
a sort of racist reaction to the civil
rights act of the 1960s
and then meanwhile gates
and his fellow whatever
can be suspected of having committed
pretty serious crimes
and they just walk around they often
never even get charged and when they do
it's all done very respectfully to their
image and to their pr uh even when there
is in the case of gates corroborating
witnesses corroborating witnesses who
are cooperating as we know jared
greenberg i think is the guy's name and
the example of gates so you know trump
likes to talk about two justice systems
the one for right wingers and the one
for everybody else it's a completely
bogus framing of the entire issue we do
have two justice systems in the united
states i've talked about it for a long
time it's people in positions of power
and who have money and who have
influence and then everybody else
and uh we are definitely seeing that
with trump and his cronies and the
people around him and maybe also with
matt gates the reason for gates wanting
this pre-emptive blanket pardon
we can speculate maybe at some point we
will know but it's a real question mark
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries is curiosity
stream one of our sponsors if you love
documentaries like me
you should really check out
curiositystream they've got all the
newest and best documentary titles tons
of stuff i can't find on netflix or hulu
and curiosity stream is only 125 a month
when you use my link below if you're
looking for those new award-winning
documentaries they've got them if you're
looking for the classics from years ago
they have those as well i just watched a
fantastic documentary called deep time
history which goes into
early
like pre-history
fascinating and curiosity stream has an
app for all of your devices tv phone
computer whether you want to watch a
serene nature documentary on the couch
or check out a juicy political
corruption story curiosity stream has
you covered you can get curiosity stream
for 15 bucks a year that's a dollar
twenty five a month only when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below